this is a production of cornell
university
so welcome everybody hello my name is
tony barracco and i currently assist
zachary stancil who is our hemp curator
at the usda ars
and
we help
run this hemp germplasm repository which
you can think of as a seed bank
and so our goal is to
collect a diverse genetic
hemp
and our second goal is to make this
diverse population of hemp available
and so
we all of this information that we
gather will be available on grin global
and that will be a tool that
researchers and educators can use
to replicate findings
and
have better reliable information
and so
today i would like to introduce our
speaker uh ethan russo he's a board
certified neurologist
psychopharmacology researcher and author
he is the founder and ceo of cradu
science
previously he was the director of
research and development of the
international cannabis and cannabinoids
institute based in prague czech republic
and he was a medical director of phytex
a biotechnology company researching and
developing innovative approaches to
targeting the human endocannabinoid
system and from 2003 to 2014 he served
as senior medical advisor medical
monitor and study physician to gw
pharmaceuticals in the united kingdom
for numerous phase one to three clinical
trials of sativex for alleviation of
cancer pain unresponsive to optimized
opioid treatment
and initial studies of epiduralx for
interactable
in intractable epilepsy so without
further ado i'll give ethan the room and
take us away ethan thank you thank you
so much it's a pleasure to be with you i
should mention that
my late father was an alumnus of cornell
uh starting back i believe in 1938
um anyway so it's a pleasure to be with
you
so i have a
difficult task today to sort of
summarize the endocannabinoid system and
the pharmacology of hemp but i tried to
make this complementary to other
lectures in the series
my email is listed here and i'd be happy
to hear from you with questions
subsequently
uh this is my disclaimer i'm not going
to spend a lot of time on this i deal
with a lot of different companies in one
capacity or another most of these have
not been remunerative and they would
have no bearing on the particular
content today
the material that i'm going to discuss
is mostly not
approved by the u.s food and drug
administration if people were to use any
of these materials the results might
vary
so we're talking of course about
cannabis sativa cultivated cannabis
this is how we came to learn of the
thing called the endocannabinoid system
so this makes cannabinoids in glandular
trichomes on unfertilized female
flowering tops
that give us tetrahydrocannabinol
and it was through research of this
molecule
that it was discovered that there were
endogenous cannabinoids uh particularly
anandamide and two arachidonyl glycerol
that actually lodge on cannabinoid
receptors
and so these are called endocannabinoids
um
the
endocannabinoid system is an internal
homeostatic regulatory system in
chordates and there are three components
the endogenous cannabinoids as mentioned
the cb1 cb2 and what's called the trip
v1 receptor probably other receptors
such as serotonin
1a receptor also includes the regulatory
enzymes
in the nervous system
the endocannabinoids are produced on
demand and travel in a retrograde
fashion to the cb1 receptor where they
then inhibit the release of
neurotransmitters
in this instance glutamate is a
stimulatory neurotransmitter so if if
this is inhibited there's a net loss of
function
if however
there are
is gaba here which is an inhibitory
neurotransmitter the net effect is a
stimulation
in the endocannabinoid system there are
probably 98 other molecules that
resemble anandamide and
on these active and inactive components
work together in what's been called an
entourage effect
the cb1 expression brain is extensive
there actually are more cb1 receptors
than there are for all the
neurotransmitters combined
cb1 is highly expressed in areas of the
brain that pertain to pain responses
balance
emotion
and reward pathways
and although uh it also is in the
brainstem they're barely any cannabinoid
receptors in the medullary areas that
subserve respiratory drive
and so there is no
dose of thc or related cannabinoids that
can cause apnea or stopping breathing
like the opiates do
the endocannabinoid system is also
throughout the other areas of the
nervous system including the spinal cord
the periphery and the gut the enteric
nervous system
the role of the endocannabinoid system
has been summarized as relaxed eat sleep
forget and protect but we could provide
about 30 other adjectives
that would also apply
and so it is the thing that modulates
pain memory movement emotion appetite
uh whether someone will vomit or not
have a seizure or not
gastrointestinal movement and secretion
and just about any other function
there are also cb2 receptors these are
mainly peripheral this is a
non-psychoactive receptor that modulates
immune responses and inflammation
it also has an anti-fibrotic effect
so there are many conditions
where
stimulation of this system can be
helpful
the cb2
has been
typified as a protective system for all
these different organs and we'd single
out the liver where
stimulation of this would seem to have a
role in preventing cirrhosis and other
problems in the liver
it's also in the skin both cb1 and cb2
the familiar cannabidiol
in addition to being anti-inflammatory
and bacteriostatic it works in another
receptor called trip v4
and actually inhibits the release of
sebum which is the oily stuff on the
skin that
is the
place where the bacteria that produce
acne feed
and again throughout the body although
this looks like a heartless and
spineless individual
all those functions are also subserved
and modulated by the endocannabinoid
system in fact cannabidiol was recently
shown to stimulate bone fracture healing
and may actually be indicated for
athletes in the future if the laws
change
now let's turn to the plant which i
think is going to be of more interest to
this audience
so again cultivated cannabis
uh probably the most useful single plant
on earth
in that it provides food from the seed
fuel from the seed oil fiber from the
stocks and pharmacy mainly from the
unfertilized female flowering tops
and this is a diacious annual that's
been assigned to the cannabisi family
along with hops and a few others
whoops
there is a chemical typology of cannabis
that was developed by ernest small going
back
clear into the 70s
type 1 is the more familiar high thc
quinovar's chemical varieties
there are no strains in cannabis strains
are for bacteria and viruses
type 2 is mixed generally with thc and
cbd of equal proportions
type 3 of the cbd predominant chemovars
that have come into the fore
particularly
since the farm bill
um this is from an article a few years
back and it shows the different parts of
the plants and the heterogeneous
production
of chemicals in the different parts
again the greatest concentration of
cannabinoids and
monoterpenoids and sesquiterpenoids is
in the
glandular trichomes of the unfertilized
female flowering tops
but they're totally different chemicals
in the roots tri-terpenoids and
alkaloids and in the seeds we have
essential fatty acids
high quality a dust and protein on their
various
anti-inflammatory compounds throughout
um in terms of the distribution of thc
and other cannabinoids this again is
greatest in the ganjar sensamiya
unfertilized female flowering tops much
greater than those that are fertilized
and very much higher than the leaves and
there's almost none elsewhere
uh close up of the capital glandular
trichomes these are of the highest
volume uh these are found on the brats
around the unfertilized female flowers
as opposed to sessile trichomes found in
the leaves of a much
smaller volume also qualitatively
different these tend to be higher in
bitter sesquiterpenoids that discourage
discourage grazing such as by beer and
other ungulates
um these are the 12 best typified
phytocannabinoids cannabinoids from
plants
we see the familiar thc in cannabidiol
um
and we've also got the uh cannabinoid
acids that are the precursors in the
fresh state
um each of these has unique pharmacology
and we'll get into that in a little bit
this is the biosynthetic pathway of the
cannabinoids generally starting with
these two precursors all of a tolic acid
with a five carbon pentyl side chain and
geranile pyrophosphate
so these start out
being the parent compounds for
cannabidiolic acid
and subsequently that goes down to
tetrahydrocannabinolic acid thca and
cannabidiolic acid
any of these under heat or light will
get decarboxylated to the neutral
cannabinoids
now
journal pyrophosphate can also react
with diverinic acid which is has got a
propyl side chain
and this produces the propyl
cannabinoids that we see on this side
additionally journal pyrophosphate is
also the parent compound to the
monoterpenoids and the sesquiterpenoids
um so
the
terpenoids and
the cannabinoids are both produced in
glandular trichomes and they're half
siblings based on a common parent
why does the plant make these well i can
tell you i was not put on god's green
earth to get people high
um
humans are per perhaps several hundred
thousand years old this plant is 30
million years old
but the endocannabinoid system has been
present in the animals for uh 600
million years
so just uh get an idea of the ontogeny
of this all
but thc
is production is greatest in bright
light and it may be
there to reduce ultraviolet light damage
to the genome
cbg and cbd are both anti-fungal
uh the trichomes
form a mechanical insect trap
and uh some of the acid cannabinoids are
actually insecticidal they also produce
necrosis and plant cells
a bushy plant at the beginning will
prune itself towards the end to look
more like this very lanky and this is
its final efforts at gaining
fertilization which we humans
prevent
to increase the amount of cannabinoids
so talking about thc
so this obviously is the major
psychoactive component of cannabis
uh not isolated and identified until
1964 by professor micholim in israel is
still still active at age 91.
it is a weak partial agonist that both
the cb1 and cb2 receptor
uh
is pain killing analgesic prevents uh
itching
also bronchodilatory in the 19th century
uh
cannabis cigarettes were used to treat
asthma it's also a neuroprotective
antioxidant it has 20 times the
anti-inflammatory power of aspirin and
twice that of hydrocortisone
so muscle relaxant that's the basis for
the approval of satellites in 30
countries to treat spasticity might
muscle tightness associated with with
multiple sclerosis
it's well known as an antiemetic helping
prevent nausea and vomiting and
chemotherapy patients
on it is neither a cox-1 or cox-2
inhibitor like the non-steroidals a very
interesting property is it seems to
prevent
a buildup of beta-amyloid and
alzheimer's disease
cannabidiol
is
not intoxicating it is psychoactive
however
on its pharmacology is actually broader
although this is much less potent
molecule per molecule
it was isolated in 1940 but only
identified positively in 1963.
it does not bind directly to the cb1
receptors but rather is what's called a
negative allosteric modulator
it binds to another receptor and affects
the binding in a way
that reduces the psychoactive effects of
thc
again a neuroprotective antioxidant
it's stronger than vitamin c or vitamin
e in this regard
like capsaicin it is an agonist at the
trip v1 receptor
with about equal potency
it may desensitize the receptor which is
helpful in in pain responses
it also increases the gain of the
endocannabinoid system by inhibiting the
uptake of anandamide and inhibiting its
breakdown
contrary to popular belief
this is a stimulatory compound
uh it's an anti-convulsant this is the
basis for its fda approval
as epi dialects in treating gervais and
lennox gastow syndromes in high doses it
is an anti-anxiety agent
cannabidiol
like the other cannabinoids has a
cytotoxic effect against multiple
cancer cells
while at the same time being
preservative for normal cells so this is
quite different to conventional
pharmacology
agents used in chemotherapy that tend to
be generally toxic
um
it also acts on a thing called tumor
necrosis factor alpha which is uh
important in rheumatoid arthritis
inflammatory bowel diseases and other
autoimmune diseases again not a coccyx1
or cox2 inhibitor
our group identified this as an agonist
at the serotonin 1a receptor and that's
the basis for its effect on anxiety
also to reduce damage due to strokes
and
problems in thinking related to
liver failure
it also works on the adenosine receptor
a2a
may have a role in preventing slow virus
infection and as mentioned previously
stimulates bone fracture healing
now there are a lot of misconceptions
about cannabidiol
a lot of companies sell products where
there's a tiny amount five milligrams
here 10 milligrams there
generally when cannabidiol is used as an
isolate very high doses are needed to
have the desirable effects
again uh it's commonly reported to be a
sedative uh but it's not
uh the early chemovars in available in
the u.s with cannabidiol in them tended
to be very high in mercy of sedating
terpene
on this produce the misconception
that it's sedative
uh you will hear that this is legal in
all 50 states but this is still a matter
of debate yes
certain commerce in canada was allowed
under the agriculture farm bill in 2018
but it remains a schedule one product
outside of its use as epidiolex
um so uh according to the fda uh it's
still
illegal
um
there's also a misconception that it
turns to thc in the body uh last year a
group in brazil had um a
very interesting trial they used
hundreds of milligrams of pure
cannabidiol
in a great number of patients and
recovered no thc
as a metabolite
this is a schematic of the natural
history of
cbd from a hemp field in kentucky
showing the glandular trichomes
then again the biosynthetic pathway to
cannabidiolic acid which is
decarboxylated by heat lighter aging to
produce cannabidiol
this is what the pure crystals look like
and
um again
in normal hepatic metabolism
we get seven hydroxycannabidiol
we don't get
thc
now we're going to turn to some
applications
um first epilepsy is mentioned uh cbd as
epidiolex has been approved
to treat a couple of rare but important
seizure syndromes called gervain lennox
gusto syndromes
but at very high doses
thcs all can be pro convulsion produce
seizures and rodents at extreme doses
but this is not substantiated in humans
um
there are other anti-convulsants in
cannabis including tetrahydrocannabin
lenol which is a terpenoid on likely
tetrodocannabinolic acid
interestingly although
in full spectrum products
um
reportedly there have been results in
treating seizures that are as good
as cbd at about five times the dose
now to be fair
um epidialex went through
randomized controlled trials whereas
these other preparations these are
observations um that were not controlled
with placebos
cbd is also
been used in on
treating schizophrenia
thc as cannabis is widely used by
psychotic patients perhaps trying to
cover some symptoms
we know that early use in the
susceptible patient may precipitate
earlier expression
of schizophrenia but only in those with
a seeming predisposition in other words
there's no evidence that you make
someone schizophrenic if they did not
have a predisposition before that
there have been two phase two randomized
controlled trials of cbd at high doses
in the 800 to 1000 milligram day range
uh both
uh effective on positive and negative
symptoms of schizophrenia
equivalent to the results with atypical
antipsychotics but with fewer side
effects so this is something that
definitely should be pursued
um the biosynthetic pathway here
is that for
cannabidirol which is the next one i'd
like to discuss and it's particularly
pertinent because there are now
chemovars of cannabis available that are
predominantly or solely can have a juror
with no thc and these can qualify
as hemp quote unquote under the farm
bill
so much as before
um we've got
olivetolic acid journal pyrophosphate to
cannabis uralic acid under heat or light
there's decarboxylation to cannabinoid
and this is a picture of a cannabidirl
only chemovar
from gw pharmaceuticals
uh the science of cbg has been less
investigated but is very uh compelling
uh this is first isolated in 1964 from
lebanese hashish again by professor
michilan and they call this the missing
link in the plant synthesis cannabinoid
constituents it is the precursor to the
others
initial studies really didn't show much
in
the animal
studies um it was synthesized in 1971
this was shown to be a gaba uptake
inhibitor
that could
explain some of the roles as a muscle
relaxant and an anti-anxiety agent
it has antifungal properties it has
analgesic painkilling properties
like tcm may lower pressure in the eye
on glaucoma although
these are greasy molecules and nobody's
figured out how to apply it directly
effectively
and um there were pain killing
properties that were noted in this
experiment
light cbd
this is cytotoxic for a variety of
cancer cells
in 2005 cbg only plant was developed it
just doesn't have the enzymatic
equipment to go beyond
cbga
this has been effective in various
cancer cell lines and breast cancer
it showed antidepressant effects in the
animals
lowers blood pressure
it may reduce the production production
of keratinocytes in psoriasis
um it has only a weak partial agonist
activity at the cannabinoid receptors a
tenth of that of thc and even in high
doses doesn't seem to be intoxicating
the way thc is
fascinating study from 2008 show
powerful antibiotic activity against
gram positives especially methicillin
resistant staphylococcus aureus
um
it also stimulates several trip channels
especially trip and mate which suggests
benefit
in bladder cancer
um and
like cbd it also inhibits a nandomite
uptake and may increase the gain of the
system
um
it
also affects uh
p part gamma nuclear receptor and down
regulated tumor necrosis factor alpha
um
and there was a recent study that showed
um
that it worked on
glioblastoma multiforme the worst form
of brain tumor
uh interestingly this
molecule both cannabidiolic acid and
cannabidiol
have been found in a south african daisy
called helichrysum on broccoli gerum but
only in trace amounts
last year
our group studied cannabidirl the first
human subject study
we
put this through an institutional review
board
worked online
and required that people be adults and
that they had used the cbg predominant
product at least 50 cbg in the past six
months
and uh this just shows the demographics
uh we had 127 completers of the survey
predominantly female
women are better at following directions
on surveys
and unlike most studies of patient
groups using cannabis the majority were
working
so unless these people
were high functioning
the average duration of use was nine
months
and
people had an average of about three and
a half grams of cbg flour a week or a
gram of concentrate a week
that's
lower than what we usually
attribute to
thc predominant chemoverse
a variety of conditions that you see
lifted on the left uh were treated uh by
these patients with cannabidiol
over half used it medically
with only a small percentage
they feel it was recreational and uh it
was a mix for of 36.2
the most common conditions cited were
anxiety chronic pain depression and
insomnia which are
quite similar to the demographics that
we see for other forms of cannabis used
therapeutically
in terms of the efficacy of the cbg
treatment the majority of conditions
reportedly were much or very much
improved
although the numbers were small on each
two thirds of the people who used
different endometriosis found it
beneficial
and three-quarters of those with
inflammatory bowel disease
um and for a greater number for
irritable bowel syndrome
um
interestingly in no instance that people
think the conventional medicine that
they had taken previously was superior
to cbg for
any of the conditions
um we're always concerned about whether
the withdrawal effects
but a number of people actually were
able to discontinue antidepressants
um non-opioid painkillers and protein
pump
inhibitors after taking cbg
in terms of side effects
44
reported none
none
um when there were side effects the most
common were dry mild sleepiness
increased appetite dry eyes which all
really are likely related to some amount
of thc in those preparations
because with cbg preparations we don't
see these complaints
10 percent reported side benefits
on terms of withdrawal from the medicine
itself
84.3 percent reported no withdrawal
symptoms
and
compared to non-cbg cannabis the more
typical thc type cannabis
there were many fewer issues
so conclusions of the survey study
we know that usage of this is increasing
particularly in the pacific northwest
where i live
this was the first study of potential
therapeutic effects in humans
anxiety pain depression insomnia were
the most commonly reported target
symptoms
the perceived efficacy was quite high
with few adverse events
um the efficacy that was reported in
inflammatory bowel diseases
also goes along with reports of cbg
being beneficial in animal models
we believe that the survey supports the
idea that cbg would be safe for future
randomized controlled trials
um how does cbg compare to cbd
well both can treat pain anxiety and
need sleep
both affect the trp channels have
antibiotic properties and are cytotoxic
for cancers and may increase
endocannabinoid tone
however cannabigirl is a lot more potent
than cbd
basically that means fewer milligrams
are necessary to be effective
for example
um anti-anxiety effects
of cbd may require 100 to 400 milligrams
whereas 10 to 20 milligrams of cbg
seem to be effective
um again cbg only chemovars are
available in some jurisdictions
whereas
it's very hard to eliminate thc
completely from type 3 cbd chemovars
compared to thc
cannabidiro likely would be a useful
adjunct to many thc chemovars by
providing synergistic benefits on pain
sleep and mood
uh because
cbg has a strong anti-anxiety effect it
may increase the therapeutic index of
thc giving you more leeway in dosing
and what do we expect from this
well what one of the things the world
needs now is a safe non-sedating
non-addictive agent to treat anxiety and
cbg may be the best candidate i've ever
seen
it seems to be quite safe and versatile
so its addition to various cannabis
based preparations makes sense
i could be an impressive agent for
primary cancer treatment
again because it kills cancer cells but
it doesn't kill normal cells
and is not intoxicating like thc
and this could be an antibiotic of the
future especially from mrsa and another
resistant bug of vancomycin resistant
enterococcus via re
on another agent in cannabis uh hard to
come by is cannabi chromine this is
produced by a recessive gene usually
there are only trace amounts if any in
most types of cannabis
it's also antibiotic and antifungal
cytotoxic
and extract produced antidepressant
effects and rodents again working on
various trip channels and inhibiting the
breakdown of anandamide
um but again selective breeding may make
this more available now turning to the
cannabinoid acids cannabidiolic acid is
what the plant makes before cbd
so this is the predominant
phytocannabinoid and fresh hemp
it is a natural herbicide
this one can produce cox inhibition but
only at extreme doses which should never
be necessary
is a powerful agent as an antimatter
preventing vomiting
this is mediated through the serotonin
receptor and it's about between 100 and
a thousand times more effective than cbd
itself
based on historical data of how hemp was
used by the renaissance herbalist
and maybe he's full on treating tumors
i think we skipped something here okay
no that's fine
um
in relation to the entourage effect we
mentioned this before
uh with the entourage of
endocannabinoids
but the same may apply to
phytocannabinoids
um quote from 1999 this type of
synergism may play a role in the widely
held but not experimentally based view
that in some cases plants are better
drugs than the natural products isolated
from them
well that was 1999 actually we have a
lot of ammunition to support the idea of
synergy of the entourage effect in
cannabis
and we see this clinically in
combinations
of full spectrum products
but again cannabis doesn't just make
cannabinoids it also makes the
terpenoids which may be painkillers
anti-inflammatory have mood modulating
effects and reduce the side effects of
thc
we see here
some of the main
terpenoids found in cannabis also other
plants
that are common to produce the same ones
going through these very quick quickly
um the most prevalent terpene in
cannabis is beta mercy and also found in
celery leaf
uh i call this the primary couch lock
factor in cannabis because it is
extremely sedating when combined with
thc
and the sedation is a
narcotic like effect
uh it is a painkiller but it can be
antagonized by naloxone the thing that
they give as an antidote to opioid
overdoses
so it's working through a different
mechanism
there tends to be a great deal of this
in most kinds of cannabis and we usually
want to see less
so that the results are less sedating
for the chronic pain patient
interesting but less
seen in cannabis these days is alpha
pinene
this is the most common terpene in
nature
from pine needles and other conifers
it's
bioavailable via inhalation it is a
bronchodilator like thc
it has wide spectrum antibiotic activity
its greatest effect though is as an
acetylcholinesterase inhibitor
acetylcholine is the memory molecule
neurotransmitter in the brain
and because uh
alpha pinene reduces its breakdown
its presence in cannabis may reduce or
eliminate short-term memory impairment
by thc
it also may have a neuroprotective
effect as we see here
um all this is supported by the fact
that uh
walking in a pine forest or what the
japanese call shinrin yoku or forest
bathing is very good for clearing the
head
another agent we'd like to see more of
in cannabis is d limonene the scent is
going to be familiar to anyone who's
been near citrus
whether it be lemons limes oranges etc
in humans this has had a potent
antidepressant and immune stimulating
effect
that was shown in hospitalized depressed
patients in japan
lowering hamilton depression scores and
allowing discontinuation of standard
antidepressants
this also may be useful as a dietary aid
it increases mitochondrial biogenesis
and may turn white fat the storage fat
of obesity into brown fat which is more
metabolically active
linoleul is a
terpenoid common to lavender well known
as an anti-anxiety agent this again has
been shown in humans particularly
demented patients with alzheimer's
disease that get um ornery at night
also prominent local anesthetic effects
and anti-convulsant effects and again
this has been demonstrated clinically
uh caryophyllene is a very interesting
compound it's a sesquiterpenoid
um 15 carbons
um it has strong anti-inflammatory
properties uh comparable to
phenylbutazone that's used as a
non-steroidal in horses but not people
but unlike the non-steroidal drugs it
protects the stomach
from
from ulcers
this actually is also a cannabinoid it's
a selective cb2 agonist so it's not
intoxicating like thc but
can produce those anti-inflammatory
benefits without
producing
psychoactive effects
and um this is what's called a phytofax
demonstration of cannabinoids and
terpenoids
in this particular chemovar
are the most prevalent uh cannabinoids
this is um
cbd
and cbg
very lower
much lower amounts of thca
what patients report in terms of the
aroma and flavor have been healed
and the effects that they report this
one's high in comfort and calm
and we see the predominant
um
terpenoids here is limonene and
caryophyllene with very low mercy
so this is a type 3 because it's
predominantly
cbd
this should be a non-sedating agent
very low in thc and mercy but high in
caryophyllene lyman unit humulin
patients report comfort
and likely this would be helpful in
treating pain inflammation
and both cbd and caryophyllene can be
helpful in treating addiction
also may be good for anxiety and
depression
so this is how we analyze what's in
cannabis to see what it might be
good for in terms of treatment
and um
i would refer you to ethanrusso.org
there is a library of
all my publications in pdf form which
you can download there because it's my
personal website uh you shouldn't be
breaking any copyright laws is my
understanding
and i'll thank you for your attention
and hope that i've left plenty of time
for questions
so
thank you so much doctor so that was uh
absolutely
gripping and fascinating talk uh i
think i can speak for everyone that we
fully enjoyed it
i also want to just give a quick thanks
to our
uh interpreters that was probably tough
um
and then as well as tony george
gemma and kim as well for making this
happen so we're so so proud at the usca
plant genetics resources unit to
host this kind of knowledge and
information sharing and again we just
want to thank you dr so i believe
tony and george have
some
questions from the q a
looks like there's a lot
yup we got a lot of questions so we'll
try to get through as many as possible
um first question
are there phenotypes of cannabis
described by small published in 1975
still relevant for modern varieties is
there any research planned or currently
working on reevaluating the 0.3
threshold on thc
uh the 0.3
threshold is a political act and has
nothing to do with science
um what i would mean team to you is
uh the concentration is much less
important than the total dose
so let's say that we had material that
was
0.25
percent thc
well if you take too much of it
you could become intoxicated by the same
token you could have five percent thc
material but if only a small amount is
taken
it would not necessarily be intoxicating
so
to be fair this was an effort to allow
commerce and
material that the government hoped would
uh not create other problems but what's
happened is
people have taken the abundant biomass
of cbd predominant material and
transmogrified it into delta a thc and
other items
which clearly are intoxicating
so we obviously need to do better and my
suggestion would be that uh
the politicians speak more to scientists
that are experienced in this area
awesome um another question comes in uh
do you do other plant groups produce
cannabinoids at all
yeah i've got a an article that's on the
website etheremuso.org
called beyond cannabis plants in the
endocannabinoid system
in terms of things that might be
cannabis like there is a component of
kavakava
piper methysticum called yangan that
seems to be an agonist at cb1
there's also the new zealand uh
liverwort radula marginata that has
thc like molecules but
the problem there is this is a rare
plant it grows a millimeter or two a
year
so the prospect that this is ever going
to be um
an agricultural crop is probably minimal
um
uh and there are lots of other examples
um
there are things that um
that work on uh various receptors of the
broad endo
endocannabinoid dome
um
and even uh prebiotics and probiotics
affect endocannabinoid
the endocannabinoid system so
um yeah that article would point um to
other
plants foods and crops um
that
could be leveraged to benefit uh
endocannabinoid system
okay awesome
um a question from ernie siebert from
alabama a m asks is the american medical
association and the nai and the nih on
board with full-scale clinical trials
research and prescribing cannabinoids to
patients
um
i i i'm afraid he's asking the wrong
person
i've been doing this for 26 years um i
tried to do clinical trials of cannabis
and migraine back in the 90s
and really got stonewalled i got the fda
cleared it but the national institute on
drug abuse had then and pretty much
still has a monopoly on the supply and
would not provide
the material
for those clinical trials
although the situation has improved
um it's testament to the fact that it's
still hard to do this kind of work i've
spent most of the last 26 years working
for foreign companies um there's a
reason for that um so yeah there's a lot
of room for improvement in
the capability to do this kind of
research which should not be seated to
other countries around the world
awesome
question comes in
would you elaborate a little further on
why
cannabis is
not referred to as a strain
um
i'm going with
i investigated this and um the
article by lewis at all in which i was
co-author uh we go into some detail on
this
um
strains is a useful term for uh
for viruses and bacteria
a
better term
for cannabis would be chemical varieties
chemo bars or even cultivars
and this also should be used instead of
the terminology sativa and indica which
have nothing to do with the taxonomic
descriptions
of the plant in the 18th century
by linnaeus and la merc
so what's called indica today doesn't
look at all like what lamarck described
um you know he
he had precedence uh
as best we can ascertain there's one
very uh promiscuous species of cannabis
um you can interbreed any
type of cannabis with another
but what differentiates them
is their effects and this is mediated by
their chemical contents and that's why i
prefer the term chemor
awesome
uh tyler gordon asks can cbg be
manufactured in a lab or is it easier to
extract from plants
uh yes it can be made biosynthetically
um they're various groups working with
yeast and e coli to uh biosen
biosynthetically produce
cannabinoids
however
this hasn't been scaled up to be
uh practical yet
can it be done likely however this is a
weed
it's relatively easy to grow if you know
how and um
additionally
um i i think i'm no luddite i think the
science of the biosynthetic approaches
is fascinating however
to me it will never equal what the plant
can do
this is a plant that from its flowering
tops can produce upwards of 30 percent
cannabinoids
which is phenomenal for any secondary
metabolite of a plant
i i'm not sure of a parallel to equal it
additionally it doesn't produce one
thing generally it produces this
entourage of compounds that are
synergistic to one another and no
bacterium or yeast is going to do that
it will never happen so i'm a strong
proponent of of the plant i'd also add
the genome of the cannabis plant is so
plastic
that
you can make it do anything you want
through good selective breeding with
conventional methods
i'm not a fan of genetic modification
and particularly for cannabis this
should never be necessary because you
can make it do almost anything you want
awesome uh another question from dr
sarah eichler asks is research on
potential agricultural pest control
applications using various cannabinoids
available
uh yeah it's a very interesting question
on the credo science website you'll see
that one of our projects relates to
development of cannabis-based treatment
for head lice
obviously
through the question it was understood
that their insecticidal properties
of the acid cannabinoids in particular
so yes this could be leveraged to
produce agricultural products that would
be safer
as
not just insecticides but possibly as
herbicides as well
so we're really interested in this so
far
this
hasn't taken off in the industry
probably
because of remaining
constraints on
with legalization i think
this would be an avenue of greater
interest
we certainly are interested in it
awesome uh
someone asks are any of the compounds
full agonists at cb1 or cb2
uh no fortunately and that's a good
thing
um even thc alone is really too strong
um thc is a synthetic it's been
available as an fda approved drug called
marinol since 1985. however it's had
very poor uptake and the reason is
most people can't tolerate it
tends to produce dysphoria unhappiness
rather than euphoria
and even experienced cannabis uh users
don't tend to like it
um
we do see full agonists
among the synthetic cannabinoids k2
spice and the like
that are very prevalent as alternatives
to cannabis again
this is a byproduct of prohibition for
the most part those aren't identified on
urine drug screens and so people turn to
them but those are overtly dangerous
the endocannabinoid system is very
subtle system
it needs gentle nudges not huge pushes
pharmacologically as would be provided
by pure thc or a full agonist that the
cbm1 receptor
um
there may be
a natural
full agonist in the form of thcp
tetrahydrocannabifural which is like thc
but with the seven carbon side chain um
however this has only been found so far
trace amounts and that's just as well
because it's 23 times more potent
than thc itself
awesome uh
one question i think is directed towards
your cbg study and they're asking uh
what were the doses used um with the
many promising results and
at those doses what were the negative
side effects found and how complete are
the risk assessment um yeah the exact
dosing again would depend on how often
the person used it a day so we couldn't
stratify the data that way however we
know
from speaking to people and observations
that
um
10 to 20 milligrams at a time seems to
be quite effective
for most people for most things
particularly in treating anxiety
i know of people inhaling 40 milligrams
of pure cbg at once
with no adverse events
so i don't know what the upper limit is
it probably is very high because it's
just not
intoxicating
and there's no withdrawal
effect so
um you know
less is more if a person is getting the
desired effect at a lower dose that's
what we recommend there's no point in
wasting
material even if it doesn't have obvious
side effects
um another question asked do you know of
any early production of since amelia
cannabis prior to the 1970s it would
seem that it would have happened earlier
given human plant understanding yeah um
there's a place called india where ganja
has been grown for thousands of years so
this is a technique
that was known to the ancients
awesome
um
someone asks dr russo would you say that
the misconception of sedation can be
related to the actual receptor behaviors
while connecting and inner working
within the anatomy
i think this relation of cbd
yeah in this instance again
at extreme doses like 1500 milligrams a
day cbd has been observed to produce
sedation but this is in the context
of patients on polypharmacy generally
these are patients with severe epilepsy
that are on scads of drugs at once
and so there are drug drug interactions
additive sedation etc
but at low and moderate doses
cbd is stimulating um i have friends in
california that use a dose of cbd in the
morning instead of caffeine these days
so
yeah and that's been tested by
electroencephalography
and sleep studies etc
um great another question comes from
phoenix saying thank you for your
contributions to cannabis uh what is the
status of the current research on chs
which i believe he means cannabinoid
hyperemus
syndrome i said that right
um yeah there are two articles on our
website on the
uh
ethanrusso.org the library and beyond
the first page
um we did a survey um that's the largest
database to date on cannabinoid
hyperemesis syndrome for those not
familiar
there is a small subset of people who
use cannabis chronically in high amounts
that develop a syndrome of abdominal
pain nausea vomiting
and with a strange behavior of hot water
bathing sometimes hours a day to allay
symptoms
this affects certain people and not
others we hypothesized that there was a
genetic cause
and that turned out to be true we
identified five
statistically significant mutations
in chs patients as compared to control
patients who use cannabis at high rates
but did not have the symptoms
and so that's available there's also a
commercial test
that's available and
that's accessible at what dash is dash
chs.com
um
and again the paper is there off
for
you to download
awesome um somebody's asking uh does cbd
work better with a small amount of thc
included
absolutely
now i'm fond of saying that there's
nothing that cbd does
that can't be enhanced by a tiny amount
of thc i mean this is the way it in
comes in nature invariably
epidiolex um
probably is the
97
pure because the fda
was thc phobic they didn't like the idea
of
giving thc to kids even though
the benefits would far outweigh the
risks
these children with
lennox gastow and gervais syndrome are
severely cognitively impaired
in general and
have sometimes hundreds of seizures a
day
so any negative effect of thc is
really
pales in comparison to the benefits it
might have
therapeutically
awesome um there's another question
related to the cannabinoids and
insecticides and this is basically
asking
um
are there any terpenes like alpha pinene
or limonene used as insecticides yeah
absolutely
so yeah i mean basically the cannabis
flower
is really designed to keep the insects
at bay um so their insecticidal
properties from the cannabinoids the
turbinoids and also
um if an insect touches the uh trichome
it'll tend to burst
and then polymerize and so there's a
mechanical insect trap
um so it's a really elegant system
to try and control predation
awesome um
i think we have time for
maybe one last question so uh have fungi
or mycotoxins been looked at as a
trigger or factor for hyper hyperemesis
conditions yeah that ain't it
that the symptoms don't match also
implicated by some people
have been pesticides and neem
but the
the toxicology of those substances
doesn't match chs and we've identified
uh the genetic cause
unfortunately people are always looking
for other explanations and find it hard
to believe that thc is the culprit
um so in this instance it's too much of
what can be a good thing is a bad thing
for
certain people
so uh
we've really bombarded dr russo with a
lot of great questions today and i i
just want to thank you again so much for
your vast knowledge and insights i i
know i've learned a lot i hope
everyone else has as well so
thank you once again on behalf of the
usda plant genetics resources unit and
cornell
university at cornell agritech so
once again thank you and uh
it was a real pleasure
thank you appreciate it
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu